connected to a panther goddess immunity
to Magic the Black Panther is even
cooler than you think here's everything
you need to know
technically black panther is not a
single person but rather a title that
has been passed down through the
monarchy of wakanda the incumbent is
also the leader of the panther tribe and
is tasked with protecting their country
and people from all threats while the
role is hereditary that doesn't mean
that the heir to the throne is
guaranteed to become a black panther as
they must first prove they are worthy of
taking up the mantle two of the first
black panthers included the legendary
bashenga and his predecessor MOSI who
ruled wakanda in the 8th Century BC and
one Million BC respectively the
character most commonly associated with
the Black Panther moniker is t'challa
the son of t'chalka he ends up becoming
a hero not just for wakanda but for the
entire world fighting alongside
superhero teams such as the Avengers and
the Fantastic Four while revealing his
home nation to other countries
in both his movie form as part of the
MCU and the Comics Black Panther has a
range of skills and abilities that make
him a challenging adversary he's capable
of fighting the Winter Soldier and
holding his own in the battle his powers
can largely be equated to the effects of
the super soldier serum making him as
strong and durable as characters like
Captain America
captain
I won't ask a second time
according to the official Handbook of
the Marvel Universe number two the hero
is stronger than any standard human and
easily able to outclass olympic-level
athletes in strength and speed
challenges he can lift more than four
times his own body weight run its speeds
exceeding 40 miles per hour and sustain
strenuous physical activity for hours on
end without being fatigued he's
essentially at the peak of human
condition for all of these attributes so
that he can pull off impressive Feats
like being able to hold his breath for
almost 10 minutes or leap across entire
buildings all of these abilities come
together to make t'challa one of the
best hand-to-hand fighters in the entire
Marvel Universe often cited in the top
10 alongside the likes of Wolverine and
Iron Fist
come on
really
another aspect that was powered up by
eating the heart-shaped herb was Black
Panther's senses all of his mental
faculties and senses have been
heightened as a result of his connection
to the panther goddess past who acts as
his Patron though his senses are not
quite as powerful as other Heroes such
as Daredevil they have impressive
practical uses for example his sense of
smell can distinguish between hundreds
of people and even hunt them using their
scent black panther volume 3 number 25
states that he can pick up the scent of
someone he is tracking and follow them
across vast distances as well as being
able to memorize and recognize
individuals from their smell alone from
a person's body odor he can even tell if
they're afraid or lying along with the
capacity to see more clearly including
in the infrared and electromagnetic
spectrums black panther can pick out
individual ingredients in the food he
eats all of this makes him a formidable
opponent when it comes to trying to
escape from or deceive him as the
augmented senses give t'challa and
massive advantage
although t'challa is undoubtedly well
trained and naturally talented the
source of most of his powers is the
Panzer goddess known as best this deity
has long been associated with the
country of wakanda and the panther tribe
in particular according to the official
Marvel site the God is inspired by
deities from the Egyptian Pantheon and
in the fictional history of the comics
was first worshiped in the country along
with her father raw and sister sekhmet
after several thousand years Bast and
segment began to be worshiped in wakanda
and bestowed Their Blessings on those
deemed worthy Bast blessing is most
closely associated with the Black
Panthers who lead the official state
religion of wakanda the panther cult
first emerged when peshenga fought
against the mutated wakandans who had
been transformed by the vibranium meteor
that hit the land he was made into an
avatar of the panther God to Aid his
cause and this connection to Bast
allowed the Black Panthers to rule
wakanda for Generations the descendants
of bashenga have subsequently sought the
favor of bass so they them selves can
have the power and authority to lead
as part of the process of becoming a
black panther and gaining the blessing
of Bast individuals have to go through a
series of dangerous trials this ranges
from challenging the incumbent black
panther if they are still alive as well
as fighting Warriors from the tribes in
wakanda only someone who is capable of
beating all of these opponents is deemed
worthy although there are other trials
that must be completed as well
enough
[Music]
the final step to becoming a black
panther is to consume the mystical and
rare heart-shaped herb this plant is
said to be a gift from the panther
goddess herself but is actually the
result of the vibranium meteorites that
hit Wanda during prehistoric times
causing radiation to mutate and
drastically change all life around it a
solution is made using the plant that is
then applied to the body of the
prospective black panther which can also
be consumed however the heart-shaped
herb is dangerous in its own right and
capable of killing those who come in
contact with it if they don't have the
protection That Bass offers
healing factors are not rare in the
world of Marvel Comics most fans will
know of Wolverine's ability to repair
himself after sustaining incredible
amounts of damage in some cases even
recovering from his body being
completely destroyed in fact the idea of
super healing has become something of a
Trope in the fictional universe that
Marvel has created with the likes of
Blade Deadpool and the Hulk all
demonstrating an ability to heal much
faster than normal humans can t'challa
doesn't have as potent a healing Factor
as many other Marvel characters but he's
still capable of healing from minor
injuries at a rapid rate as well as
providing some immunity to diseases and
poisons it means that small wounds and
scrapes won't keep him out of action
when in a fight killing black panther is
extremely difficult and only serious
injuries would ensure that he can't get
back up to fight like many of his other
powers this healing Factor manifested
after he consumed the mystical
heart-shaped Earth
as the king of wakanda t'challa has
access to a vast amount of wealth fandom
suggests that the hero May well be the
richest superhero in comic book history
his fortune largely comes from wakanda
itself a rich and thriving nation that
has huge reserves of vibrania the
impressive effects of the ore have made
it much sought after and Black Panther's
wealth dwarfs that of other Rich Heroes
such as Iron Man
me the country has National reserves in
the trillions of dollars and it's
Diversified its Investments so that it
doesn't have to rely solely on vibranium
for its wealth shut off from the rest of
the world wakanda was largely Untouched
by the Troubles of the world throughout
its history and has become the most
advanced nation in the world due to its
technology the effects of this
incredible wealth and technology is that
the King has access to the very best
training facilities and Equipment this
allows him to hone his skills to
Perfection and ensures he only gets the
best including his gadgets and the
vibranium least suit he takes into
battle his decision to open wakanda up
to the world has also brought him strong
allies and increased diplomatic
relations with other nations the suit
that black panther wears officially
known as the panther habit also boosts
many of his innate abilities made with
vibranium the same material used in the
construction of Captain America's shield
it makes the wearer invulnerable to many
types of damage it can even absorb the
impact of gunshots at close range and
other powerful attacks the movie version
of the high-tech suit comes with
retractable vibranium claws for Close
Quarters combat and is made lightweight
so that it doesn't restrict the hero's
movement in battle it's also able to
absorb kinetic energy and disperse it to
augment Black Panther's own physical
attacks his special outfit can operate
in a similar manner to Spider-Mans
allowing him to grip walls and climb
buildings that would otherwise be
impossible to mount the suit also gives
black panther an advanced cloaking
ability that can make him practically
invisible the technology is especially
useful when it comes to stealthily
avoiding detection and infiltrating
enemy headquarters his boots can also
allow him to drop from Great Heights
unharmed or leap long distances with
Grace and ease
fans who know of Black Panther from the
MCU films might not be aware that the
character is as impressive and intellect
as he is a fighter but it's true black
panther could even be compared to the
likes of Batman from DC Comics in terms
of intelligence he's a character who's
capable of out thinking his opponents as
well as overwhelming them in battle
Incredible Hulk Number 601 noted that he
was considered among the smartest people
living on the planet while Fantastic
Four number 608 demonstrated that only
Reed Richards was able to keep up with
him mentally the official Handbook of
the Marvel Universe Master Edition
number nine even reveals that he has
something of a photographic memory and
can replicate almost any technology that
he has given the chance to study even
briefly
along with his resistance to disease and
poison thanks to the power of the
heart-shaped herb and the blessing of
Bast black panther has also acquired
protection against magic this happened
during the Doom War series when Dr Doom
was able to effectively remove all of
t'challa's powers and force the mantle
of black panther to be passed on to
t'challa's Sister shuri Doom himself
even tries to prove his worthiness to
Bast at one point to try and become the
leader of wakanda in an effort to get
back his powers by other means t'challa
worked with the sorcerer's olivari to
restore many of t'challa's abilities as
well as some new ones Chief among them
was resistance to almost all forms of
magic making mystical attacks almost
useless against black panther
as well as his arsenal of abilities and
Powers most people are familiar with
there are a few less well-known examples
that many fans will be completely
unaware of one of the stranger powers
that t'challa has demonstrated during
his long history includes necromancy
Secret Wars number seven which was
released in 2015 sees the king of
wakanda work with Namor and Reed
Richards to raise an army of zombies to
fight against Victor Von Doom after
striking a deal with the panther goddess
the deity gives the hero the ability to
communicate with the dead and raise them
as soldiers to fight on his behalf
t'challa becomes one of several Marvel
characters who've had a brush with the
undead in the comics the heart-shaped
herb that t'challa had to eat as part of
the ritual to become black panther also
allows him to communicate with his
ancestors in the afterlife other
examples have been powers that black
panther has only possessed for a short
amount of time or in one-off stories in
Incredible Hulk Number 601 he uses a
teleportation device that he's created
himself to travel large distances in
instantaneously meanwhile one storyline
saw the hero able to exercise
Clairvoyance so that he could see into
the future and witness events yet to
occur
[Music]
[Applause]